[Music]
in got jack'd news submitted by chu from
Elk Grove oh that Sacramento rapper
sakauchi 69 was hospitalized after being
pistol-whipped and robbed damn does
anybody know why he chose a Japanese
name he's not Asian
he always has multicolored hair yeah
yeah rainbow hair
licky licky see you see you go oh this
guy you got a tattoo all over the face
guy special he's this one he talks like
mad [ __ ] but he's actually like a super
troll and he's like really funny a lot
of people are thinking that this whole
thing was just another troll I've seen
him somewhere people don't believe if
the story is true or not because he
trolls like so much he's literally the
boy who cried one last man you can't use
the same beer you funny thing was like
people also think he might have got
jumped through because like he's thing
was he always to be like yo I could go
anywhere I want no one's gonna touch me
no one's gonna [ __ ] with me I go to like
dangerous parts of whatever and nothing
so untouchable if you walk around
looking like a gangster Prince like he
could have been Prince back in the day I
used to like nah [ __ ] would I used to be
like I'm so over this dude like this he
cuz all he did was like talk [ __ ] like
ya hate the catchy songs but he's all
just talking [ __ ] and just like yeah
just starting up drama
but then it was like yo he's funny Heike
you like he funny look at the highest
octave you guys see the video lax when
people try to jump him no people try to
jump talking [ __ ] about LA west coast
rappers so when he was my ex a bunch of
dudes try jumping him where is he from
New York New York
Oh what you're close by calling him a
prince yeah I don't think he deserves
that title that's the thing he's like
yeah you know I'm the king of New York
now but like but he's like but knows
who's [ __ ] with me no one's [ __ ]
like no one no one's no one's touching
me Nolan Shawna
you know like contest that and not like
50 cosines in like him and 50 are real
cool Oh what's a Mexican guy doing in
New York
there's no Rican Ricans and Dominicans
out there he's magic
he's Mexican it was Daniel he was reppin
for Mexico and the World Cup the first
game when they lost when they lost
there's a video of him walking barefoot
with the Mexican flag around him just
like in the middle of the street like
sad like taking naps on the street and
[ __ ] he's funny bro so I take it you'd
like him I'm a fan now because there any
like evidence of this happening he just
ya know cici tangling if he's so gangsta
right like I wouldn't want to [ __ ] let
anybody know that I got pistol-whipped
in Jack well you know that's my image
yeah it's interesting because there's
two different stories being told yes
sources close to him told media and then
there's a story that he told the cops
hmm so what about the sources telling
the media apparently he was working on a
music video in Brooklyn he wrapped up
for the night he drove home and then
when he got home a car pulled up blocked
his driveway and then that's when three
hooded gunman got out of the car grabbed
him and pistol-whipped him knocking him
unconscious and then the next thing he
knew he was in the backseat of a
different car and the gunmen were
driving around telling him that if they
didn't get what they wanted from him
which was jewelry and money that they
would kill him then the gunman pulled up
to his home and two of them made their
way inside and the third one guarded six
nine outside in the vehicle and then the
gunman ended up taking around seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
jewelry between 15,000 and 20,000
dollars in cash and then while all that
was happening his baby mama and daughter
were inside the house but they were not
hurt that's a scary though the gunman
then drove away with six nine still in
the backseat and then at some point she
was able to open the back door and he
jumped out and one of the gunmen began
chasing him but then
he got scared and retreated because he
was afraid you'd be ID'd I thought grace
is no gift scare and then that's when 69
jumped in to the passenger seat of a
stranger's car and then asked him for
help and then the stranger called 9-1-1
fast nor'easter and then imagine that
you see this boy looks like a [ __ ]
treasure trove I lost weight oh you need
help okay I jumped in my car I would
think that I was getting robbed right
helping you with the [ __ ] yes apparently
that guy told him to get out of his car
he didn't call for help but he told me
to get out of his car and then an
ambulance man yeah and then an ambulance
showed up and then took him to the
hospital and then doctors were
performing several tests including a CT
scan and then this photo was also
released I mean it looks that looks kind
of like he really got hit in the face a
couple of times yeah he looks like he
got knocked out and then all the tattoo
artists of the world busted the biggest
prank on him you see the six nines on
his yeah he's got six times everywhere
that must be his favorite sex position
you know what's better than the 69 is a
68 when is that that's where you go down
on me and I owe you one
oh I love that one it's an old joke I
don't how corny it is or you know it's
same level of corny but you know it's
better as is 96 that's where you turn
around a fart on the back back of each
other's heads back to back magic and
when you laugh later yeah yeah but son I
like spell 11 where you just like
sleeping next to each other
get your REM sleep Banyon I'm in 77 30
comfortable 77 where you just you just
doing this yeah my two cats massaging
each other two cats on a bed Tiffani's
like recess like crack me up disaster we
sales renters it okay well
how else am I supposed to bring a
backseat sorry buddy
you're doing a great job you could
borrow food and then you go so I can
help you out I can help you go ahead you
feel sorry that you ask y'all me to help
you transition actually sounds pretty
dope you gotta take it all right take it
right away all right so then six name
told a different story to the cops
what's his story I hear like I pulled up
I started fighting them I [ __ ] got
one on the chin I got the other one but
I was overwhelmed they were like 17
hello the weight TMZ is reporting in is
that the original story it makes him
sound harder than the story he told the
cops
Oh real [ __ ] there's only one guy not
three people and I was scared
so was the original story hey I robbed
myself been around for 25 a.m. he was a
passenger in a Chevy Tahoe at a Brooklyn
intersection sitting at a red lights
when a car bumped them from behind he
told the cops that two men with guns
jumped out and stole the drivers iPhone
and then grabbed 69 and dragged him into
the car and sped away then yeah they
drove him home and then he called
someone inside which was baby mama and
asked her to come down with his jewelry
which she did he told the cops that he
managed to escape and reported the
incident to the cops hmm but then
apparently he became uncooperative and
so he checked himself into the hospital
law enforcement saying that they have no
idea how he got hurt oh yeah that's
crazy so how did the first information
get out so they're saying his original
story was that he just like these guys
took him to his house he was like okay
if you want you we come get this jewelry
and then and then that was it
and then they were like and then he just
check himself in the hospital eventually
the one that he told the cops yeah yeah
pretty much
oh that's what they're saying his story
sounds like he was walking everywhere
then I walked home and then I just see
him like walking all the way to the
hospital
he is saying that he thinks it was an
inside job because when he told them
that hey there's jewelry at my place
he didn't give them an address that they
automatically anyway to go
what if his address was [ __ ] 69
Boulevard it's like literally tattooed
on his [ __ ] face the zip code is on
his [ __ ] ear 6 9 6 9 oh yeah so they
are saying that he was at a strip club
that's really famous and currently at
that strip club he was wearing a whole
bunch of expensive jewelry and he was
just like making it rain all over the
place so then there was probably people
in that strip club that saw him want
everything and then followed him home
and then did all that happens at casinos
too that happened at bars neighbor yeah
really
they ball out at the casino and then
they win big whatever and they cause a
scene and these people always scouting
you out there's people that get followed
home and they get killed and robbed
that's crazy
you got you got to win quietly if you
win a pretty big jackpot they have
security escort but the scariest time is
when you get home because where people
get you is when you open up that garage
door and then you park your car then
they start coming just like in this in
yeah because then that's the best place
to rob somebody because when they open
up the door there's nowhere else they
could go and it's hard as [ __ ] to turn
around and get out like this [ __ ] so if
someone has a gun on you you're like
[ __ ] right and then that garage is like
direct access to your house - yeah and
all they gotta do is close the door and
that's it people are watching like ok ok
I think the best thing to do is drive in
circles after you win and drive will
although to play infuse them but even if
you're not a casino guy like that's just
been one of the biggest places where
people get robbed is when you pull into
that garage or onto your driveway yeah
yeah and then there's not a lot of
places you can go and then they can
bring you right in the house yeah in a
car make sure you just give it a few
seconds close that garage door behind
you make sure a ninja didn't crawl
through have your pepper spray ready
that's another thing to ladies hold the
pepper spray when you're walking in a
suspect area don't you wait like I'm a
[ __ ] unless you're practicing
quick-draw in the purse
or keep a gun in your purse because this
happened in New York and guns aren't
even legal and they still got it this
will still got robbed so everyone has a
gun just hold it in the paper back and
have it pointed yeah
[Music]